sarah and jennifer were both from george
washington and they
are in uh they have expertise in
economics and global health and public
health
and i'm especially excited to hear from
them because
we have been collaborating on at one of
the sites
where they've been collecting data in in
bangladesh but we'll hear about work
that they're doing in multiple sites
around the world
and i guess today we'll talk a lot about
jordan and bangladesh
so thanks very very much uh sarah and
jennifer for being with us and
uh and hopefully like i remember we
actually originally scheduled this to be
in person
but hopefully at some point we can uh we
can fix that
great well thanks very much um mushvik
for the
invitation um and thanks for the
opportunity to present
today and ramadan mubarak to those of
you that um
observe so jennifer and i will be
sharing
the presentation today talking about
findings from our research on
adolescents in bangladesh and jordan
that's part of the gender and
adolescence global evidence
study these findings are on behalf of a
large
research team with researchers in the us
uk
bangladesh jordan palestine and others
and i'll provide a link to the website
at the end of the presentation so you
can learn more about
the broad collaboration um
jennifer and i are both relatively new
to research in um refugee
settings so that so we're particularly
delighted to be presenting to this
group um and we really look forward to
your questions
and insights on on you know new strands
of research we may want to pursue in
in the in the future um also you know
we're
this is a very collaborative project and
so we hope that this also opens up scope
for
for future collaboration uh next
so what we've decided to do today is to
provide kind of an overview
of the gauge project and some of the
research jennifer and ir
are working on um i think it sort of
just highlights
broadly what we're what we're doing and
hopefully um provides you
um you know you learn learn something
new um
and are excited to hear more as this
research progresses
i'll start by providing an overview of
of gage because i imagine many of you
are new um to the gender and adolescence
global evidence project
as well as why we think adolescents are
an important age group to study
particularly in refugee contexts i'll
then turn to a detailed description of
our our samples in bangladesh and jordan
which will be the focus today
um as mushvik mentioned we're lucky
enough to partner
um with him and austin and others on the
cox
bazaar panel survey which is where the
bangladesh data
comes from i'm going to hand it over to
jennifer who's going to talk about
findings related to three specific
um adolescent capabilities that map to
our gauge conceptual framework which
i'll talk about in a bit
we decided to focus on education bodily
integrity which include
includes violence in child marriage as
well as psychosocial well-being
uh jennifer will talk about sort of the
risk and and protective factors for
improved outcomes
diving deep into analysis on on mental
health
she'll also explore the role of
adolescent programming
in promoting resilience and sort of
mitigating the impact of negative shocks
um she'll then hand it back to me well i
will talk a bit about our covet 19
research in both contexts and how that
is
exacerbating existing um inequalities
for these groups and then i'll turn to
some conclusions
we're happy to take questions throughout
um and we'll also try and pause um you
know every ten minutes or so to
to to open it up for for any questions
um i wanna know from the start that
you know although jennifer and i are
both economists and
typically focus on randomized controlled
trials and and causal inference that um
today
our presentation will largely be
descriptive in nature really building on
the robust baseline data we have in
these these contexts
we will um complement this with
um some
uh new measurement work some work
combining gauge data with administrative
data and some quasi-experimental
analysis
we also have very rich qualitative data
that supports our quantitative data
which i think allows us to
dig deeper on certain things that um
perhaps
typical studies are not able to um to
dig into
and so um from there let's go to the
next slide
so let me just first provide an overview
of the gauge research
agenda which these two samples fit into
since i think
probably for many of you you're not
familiar with with this
this study next slide
so gage is a nine-year mixed methods
longitudinal research program exploring
the gendered experience of adolescents
10 to 19 years global globally we're
following around 18 000 um adolescents
close to 20 000
um boys and girls in sort of seven focal
countries
so ethiopia and rwanda nepal and
bangladesh and then palestine lebanon
and jordan
ultimately gage is interested in
exploring what works for whom where and
why so we can better support adolescent
girls and boys
um in the future the
gauge i think in particular is focused
on the most vulnerable
adolescents so this includes working
with refugee populations but also over
sampling um adolescent girls who have
experienced child marriage
and adolescents with disability so our
so we can actually kind of
quantitatively say something about these
these groups i should note that gage is
funded by
fcdo in the uk and led by the overseas
development institute in the uk
and jennifer and i um lead on the
quantitative
work next slide
so gauge um is guided by
a what we call the three c's conceptual
framework so capabilities
context and change pathways this has
been really important
um in ensuring that
these very varied research streams both
in terms of context we're working in
programs we're evaluating partnerships
etc sort of map on to some overall
framework that
helps speak more broadly to not only
what
how adolescents transition from young
adolescents to adulthood but also
how context interacts with that with
that transition
our conceptual framework is built around
six core capability domains that you see
listed
here um this draws on a marty ascends
work who argued that to achieve a
dignified life
people need a sort of core set of
entitlements or freedoms which he called
capabilities
engaged we've identified these six as
capability areas that are particularly
salient for
for adolescents and as i mentioned on
the previous slide we're going to focus
sort of dive deeper into three of them
um today i think given
both time constraints and given um
where we sort of see the most
differences between jordan and
bangladesh as well as where we actually
see some some similarities
this you know framework recognizes that
adolescence um
context at the household community
and national level are going to shape
outcomes and i think that's going to be
really highlighted in our findings today
and it also highlights the importance of
reaching adolescence through different
policies and programs and we'll speak to
some of that today as well
i'm happy to talk more about this later
on next slide
as i mentioned we're following
approximately 20 000
um adolescents globally these
include quantitative
girls and boys themselves um who
in most cohorts were aged 10 to 12 or 15
to 17 when the research started
we also survey female and male
caregivers
as well as community leaders schools
health facilities etc to better
understand the context these adolescents
live in
the quantitative data is supported by
qualitative research
and annual participatory research the
qualitative data is
you know extremely detailed
um methodologies and you know jennifer
and i neither jennifer and i
are quantitative are qualitative experts
but we're going to
also highlight support our quantitative
findings with some of the work that's
coming out of the
of the qualitative side next slide
i want to just quickly motivate why
we're focused on
adolescents why is this sort of an
interesting group to to look at
particularly in refugee contexts
so adolescence is a time where physical
transformation transformations are
large right they're going through
through puberty
and in addition um
children's place in the household
changes dramatically and it changes very
differently for boys and girls right
gendered norms become
much more salient than this time it's
also a time adolescents are particularly
vulnerable um to a wide range of
risk-taking behavior
that could jeopardize long-term outcomes
but the sort of malleability also um
ensures that this is a time where
intervention
um may be particularly salient is why
and so why researchers have
sort of now called on adolescents as
kind of a window of opportunity for
intervention right so building on the
first 1000 days to say this is another
key touch point where
intervention may be critical to promote
um
improved outcomes as adolescent age
i think you know reaching adolescents
not only
because of the there are sort of the
importance to
um good outcomes in adulthood but
adolescents are also a massive
proportion of the population right and
that's growing
so reaching adolescence is going to be
critical for
achieving the sustainability sustainable
development goals and so we really need
to understand
more about their lives across various
contexts next slide
adolescents specifically but also
refugees are
a key population for sustainable
development goal delivery
this is not an exhaustive list but we
listed here um
a subset of the sustainable development
goals and how
uh ensuring that refugees are are
looked at and considered as an important
group to reach these goals
across these different domains this
again is is further emphasized by
adolescents where
the proportion of young people among the
displaced is disproportionate right so
when we look at the kind of displaced
population globally
about 50 percent are children
as opposed to 30 of the global
population
in jordan specifically um who have taken
in more than a million syrian refugees
nearly a half are below the age of 18.
similarly
in um the rohingya refugees in
bangladesh
over 450 000 are children and 55
are under the age of 18. so sort of
adolescents
um refugee adolescents are sort of a
critical
um a critical group to to understand
um in order to meet these sustainable
development goals
can i introduce this slide please sir um
i was just wondering as you're speaking
about
refugees and adolescents whether
there's any biological or physiological
reasons for us to believe
that the act of displacement or
instability or uh exposure to
violence right which often pre-predates
like displacement um
is that differentially harmful for
adolescents relative to say adults or
relative to younger children just
getting a sense of uh
during like critical growth phases uh
what what these um
what these types of kind of um attacks
on
on on people psyche and and their
physical health
might do to them yeah great question so
you know i think obviously this the
shock of force displacement
affects all age groups and in different
ways
i think for adolescents um a few
critical things
one it often leads to fairly severe
disruptions in
in education right so they're sort of
either out of school permanently
or um out of school for long periods of
time
that's in and of itself problematic for
improved adult outcomes but also
you know particularly for girls can lead
to
early marriage early childbearing which
has its own set of health consequences
and for boys can end up in child labor
again with potential physical health
consequences another particularly
critical point for
adolescents is um mental health issues
are one of the leading
causes of disability among adolescents
with
uh i think alongside um
gonna forget but basically it's one of
the top three causes and so we know
and we also know that the majority of
mental health illnesses in adulthood
start in adolescence
and so we can see how these sort of
negative shocks from from violence
leading to um higher symptoms of
of psychosocial distress in adolescence
can then
lead to longer-term consequences and
jennifer's going to speak directly to
um the association between past exposure
to violence and
current mental health and then just
finally i think the other point is
you know we increasingly recognize um
the importance of nutrition during
adolescence and there's a lot sort of
innovative new research around an
adolescent growth spurt right so if
you've missed out in childhood you may
actually be able to catch up if you
intervene appropriately at adolescents
so again
adolescents going through forced
displacement often lack
access to enough nutritious food
which again is is challenging so i think
there are lots of reasons why
adolescents are going to face certain
important consequences from forced
displacement
sorry to extend the conversation a
little bit but
picking up from your from your response
um
so it reminds me of so this is my own
version of really low quality
qualitative data
work um which is like just having
conversations in the rohingya refugee
camps the
same places where you and i are
collecting data um
with some you know knowledgeable uh
individuals within the camps uh rohingya
growing individuals
so one of the complaints in bangladesh
has been
oh you know these rohingyas i mean so
people initially thankfully
uh welcome the refugees like remembering
that we were refugees once
but then as you probably know that over
time people have gotten more and more
um uh annoyed
or like just just getting fed up with
the situation and that
you know a lot of our land is taken up
and there's no long-term solution you
know we don't see repatriation as an
effect but
as a feasible solution to what's going
to happen and so one of you know so
there have been many complaints that
have been merging and one of the
complaints is that
fertility rates among rohingya are very
high and
you know they they have too many
children they have children early et
cetera so when you were talking about
early marriage risk etc right
so so a person who has a university
education was growing up but studied a
number of
university so he was trying to explain
to me what exactly goes on there
and his explanation was that when
uh the military right used to come in
the tatmoda attacked the villages right
they often had because
rape was used as one of the weapons
right they often had their
eyes on young girls and one of the
i guess defensive strategies that the
rohingya developed
is that whenever somebody is of age like
an adolescent like they get married off
and they try to get pregnant as quickly
as possible because that would be a way
to protect young girls
yeah so i mean i think that resonates um
with jordan
as well as i think child well so i think
two things i think one
given concerns of um rape whether by
uh you know
government forces or simply by other
people in the in the community i think
there's a sense of of
trying to ensure that the girl is
married and
etc to protect her from that possible
um violation and then second i think in
in
these contexts it's also um
seen as a way to get additional
financial support right social it's sort
of a social protection
mechanism so i think in both of these
contexts we're
seeing increased um rates of
of child marriage as for example so in
jordan for example as
some of the more global support
dissipated
sort of there was a a spike in in child
marriage because these households were
looking for for other ways to support so
i think there's sort of a sexual purity
piece of it um and then as well as in
sort of a protection around risks of
rape as well as a social protection
angle jennifer do you wanna add yeah i'm
just gonna say
um don't have it in the presentation
here but i've been working on a paper
specifically around um early marriage
and
among the rohingya in the camps and in
the qualitative work there
one of the things that came out very
strongly was exactly this
issue they discussed which is early
marriage as a way to protect
the girls from um gender-based violence
and sexual violence
um even continuing to occur in the camps
um as well and i have a couple of stats
on a few slides too moving forward
okay great um so now i'm going to talk a
little bit more about
our sample um next slide
great um so in jordan
we have a little over 4 000 adolescents
syrians vulnerable jordanians
palestinians in
gaza camp as well as a small handful of
other nationalities so iraqi pakistani
etc these adolescents were sampled
from unicef and unhcr lists
so they should be considered sort of
representative
globally of adolescents and camps and
informal attended settlements so its are
informal tended settlements
um basically any anyone living in a camp
or its would be in one of these unicef
and unhcr lists
and then it should be considered
representative of kind of vulnerable
jordanians and syrians in host
um communities the
syrians live in host formal camps and
informal attention settlements
jordanians live in host communities and
the palestinians live in one specific
camp gaza camp the syrians live in
zahari and azerok camp in our in our
sample
at baseline which was in late
2018 the majority of girls and boys were
10 to 12 and 15 to 17 and you can see
sort of
fairly equal distributions by by gender
and
age and we also have as i mentioned um
over-sampled adolescents with disability
and married adolescents to be able to
kind of speak directly to those groups
in host communities we're working in
four localities amman
mafrak arabid and jiraj so again the
jordan sample should be thought of as
broadly representative of vulnerable
adolescents and can't host and its
communities
next slide
yeah so as i mentioned we our original
survey took place in 2018 2019 when the
majority were 10 to 12 and 15 to 17
along with adolescent surveys we
surveyed primary female caregivers and
also conducted a school-based survey
we were then in i was in jordan in late
february 2020
we are about to launch our second round
of data collection
and literally the day we were supposed
to go to the fields jordan went into a
strict lockdown
around covid 19 um so we pivoted and
conducted virtual surveys
in may and july 2020 and then again in
october 2020 and january 2021
this is a sample where 99 of households
have access to a cell phone
or landline and so it's a kind of a
place as well that's very conducive to
conducting virtual surveys
and although these surveyed rates you
know 75 to 72
maybe lower than what you would see in
in-person surveys i think they're they
look relatively good
um for cobit surveys and analysis
suggests that
the we're sort of missing adolescents
largely at
random other than being slightly more
likely to find
adolescents from the younger cohort next
slide
i thought it might be helpful to just
provide some
baseline characteristics from this
sample to just help orient you to who
these are um
and how how they kind of vary um across
context so i think one important
thing that i hope comes out of our
presentation today is not only the sort
of variation between
sort of the refugee experience in
bangladesh versus jordan but also within
these contexts how varied it can be by
by gender and other characteristic so
first is just
looking at social protection so whether
the household receives food or
cash aid you can see that the majority
of syrians do have access to some sort
of
social protection support with much
lower rates for palestinians and
and jordans and jordanians um but you
can also see when you look at
um location of residents for syrians
that
social protection is basically universal
in the camps drops a little bit in hosts
and drops further in an its and
one thing that we'll see in jordan is
that that the sort of social safety net
system of the camp
um actually provide syrians and camps a
lot more
support than in host and i think that's
going to contrast to sort of the camp
experience in bangladesh
the second thing to highlight is just to
get a sense of school enrollment about
three quarters of the sample were in
school at baseline
much lower rates among syrians than
compared to palestinian and jordanians
and again
we see that rates are slightly higher in
camp followed by hosts but then
dramatically lower in
informal attendance settlements where
only 42 were in school
speaking to the specific vulnerability
of that of that group
next slide similarly when we look at
gender and marital status um
mobility is sort of a important issue
for
for these populations and this has
become increasingly apparent with the
covid
research so at baseline seventy percent
six percent of the adolescents were able
to leave their house on a daily basis
um but then you see this sort of massive
gender divide 87
of boys versus 67 of girls
and then when we look at the older girls
by marital status we can see that
married
um married girls have very little
ability to move around right so only 28
of them were able to leave their house
on a daily on a daily basis
similarly when we break school
enrollment down by by gender and marital
status
so one is we actually see that schooling
rates are similar by boys for boys and
girls and actually
across the board education outcomes in
in jordan whether it's enrollment
attainment etc tend to actually benef
benefit girls over over boys once again
we see that that married
girls not surprisingly are very unlikely
to still be in
in school and so that's sort of another
group with specific vulnerabilities
next slide so now very quickly and
jennifer's going to dive a lot more
deeper into the these these findings
um so as i mentioned um we partner with
with mushvik on the cox bazaar
uh panel survey which includes a sample
of rohingya in the
camps as well as bangladeshis in sort of
near host and further host
um communities are
the gauge piece of this sample once
again focuses on adolescents 10 to 12
and 15 to 17 with again over sampling of
adolescents with disabilities and
married adolescents um there's a very
detailed listing and
sampling process to sort of ensure
representation that these samples are
broadly representative of the camps and
the
and the hosts with a couple of
exceptions where we were unable to do
surveys in a couple of the
of the camps um next slide
so our sample here is a little over 2
000 adolescents who were first surveyed
in
sort of mid um to late 2019.
once again um we also surveyed primary
female caregivers
what's really nice here is that this
data set links to mushfix broader data
set which has a lot of household and
adult level information
both of those data sets are now in the
public domain
so i think lots of additional research
can be done
exploiting uh mushvik and austin's data
or jennifer and my data and linking the
two
as as needed so it's really been great
sort of a great way to
to partner on surveys interested in
similar populations but but different
questions
so once again we also had to pivot to
virtual surveys here
um which while in host communities
is is doable was particularly
challenging in in camps and i think
um is something we're gonna have to
think about more as we move um
forward uh but you know we did reach
about seventy percent
at covet round one and covert r2 is
actually ongoing now so we won't be able
to report yet on that second virtual
survey
round uh next slide
just to give you a sense of who this
population is
um i think you know first and foremost a
really
important um fact about the the rohingya
is they basically have no access to
formal
education in the camps and so you can
see that
camp which is is sort of synonymous for
rohingya only 3.7 percent
are enrolled in any kind of formal
school
they do have access to some informal
schooling um but that's fairly
limited and jennifer will speak to that
as well we also see that
child marriage is much higher among the
rohingya sample than it is
in host with again the majority of
marriages happening for for girls and
very few for for adolescent
um boys similar to
the note on notability on the first
slide we also
um see you know that these adolescents
have
some limited mobility here once again
the sort of massive gender divide with
78 percent of boys versus 44
of girls being able to leave their camp
block or host community at least once
per
week and so they you know these
adolescents are living fairly
constrained
lives um so any questions on on the
on the sample um before i hand it over
to jennifer to
dig into some of our findings
all right jennifer um over to you
you all right so now um
i'm going to start talking a little bit
about adolescent capabilities as
um sarah mentioned previously i'm going
to be focusing in on education and
learning
bodily integrity with a look at exposure
to violence and early marriage
and then psychosocial well-being and
within the discussion of capabilities
i will also talk a little bit about some
of the quasi-experimental work we're
doing evaluating programming that's
happening both in jordan
and in the rohingya camps
and then i'll do a deep dive sort of
into psychosocial
mental health outcomes and exposure to
violence pre-migration
um so first sort of starting with
education and learning i wanted to start
on a positive note which is that um
you know adolescent aspirations are
quite high in
in both of these contexts so in both
jordan
and bangladesh we see you know in jordan
80
over 80 percent of adolescents want to
complete at least some secondary school
and in bangladesh in our sample over 90
of adolescents want to complete at least
some secondary school
um but there's you know variation across
um
across populations even within the
various contexts so in jordan
you know the lowest level of aspirations
for secondary school is 60 of
adolescents living in these
um in its in the um
tempted communities versus 93 percent of
jordanian girls
um and then really where the stark
difference comes in
is aspirations for at least some
university so whereas in jordan um you
know 70
of adolescents want to complete at least
some university in bangladesh we see
um in this sample in cox's bazar
among the bangladeshis and rohingya
adolescence
only about 45 percent aspire to at least
some university
but this is you know driven by wide
disparities in in population so
in particular rohingya girls have very
low aspirations for
university attendance which is likely
partially reflective of
like the realities of what will be
possible for them and um as i'll be
discussing
sort of access to education is basically
non-existent for that population
um the other thing i wanted to point out
um
is that um well
actually i'll get to that in the next
slide um so
then i also wanted to point out that you
know parental aspirations
largely reflect the adolescent
aspirations themselves
um female caregivers over 95 percent in
both contacts want their child to attend
at least some secondary school
um and then for university attendance
sort of reflecting what we saw among
adolescents
um adolescence you know 88
of of parents are supportive of
university
education in in jordan versus 32 percent
of parents
um in bangladesh and again why
disparities between
sort of the bangladeshi populations and
the host communities versus
the rohingya population where you know
only
15 of rohingya parents are aspiring for
some university education
um i do want to note that actually even
comparing
the bangladeshi population in these host
communities to other contexts in
bangladesh we also do work
in um in the slums around dhaka
and in chittagong and sile among
school-going adolescence and aspirations
in those contexts are much higher for
universities so in urban slums about 71
percent of
female caregivers aspire for university
um education for their for their
children and in
um in chittagong might be school going
adolescence it's about 93
so this also points to the host
communities that we're working with in
cox's bazar are also
you know relatively more vulnerable
um so i mentioned that you know part of
the disparity
in aspirations comes from educational
realities
and um this points to access to
schooling
for rohingya is well formal schooling is
non-existent the rohingya are
um restricted to camps and are not
allowed to attend
um sort of local schools so the
schooling that they do have access to
are these informal learning centers or
temporary learning centers that are set
up within the camps which i'll talk a
bit about
more about in a moment but they really
cater to younger adolescents and
children and the very basic level
education
um and then more generally in in these
populations
um restrictive gender norms prevent
prevent girls from attending school
once they reach menstruation and and
beyond
um and you know similar patterns in in
jordan in terms of
girls facing exclusion due to
restrictive gender norms
but the picture in terms of access to
education for
um refugees is is a bit
more positive so while initially syrian
refugees faced some
rates of exclusion from education jordan
introduced a nationwide
double shift system that's increased
access to formal education
among the syrian refugees and then they
also
have this makhani non-formal education
platform that exists in the
camps host communities and um intended
settlements
that provide education
um so just to give a little bit more
context on
these education programs that exist in
both in both contexts
um in jordan this uh non-formal
education programming that's available
is called makani which translates to my
state
myspace and it's a unicef program that's
reached over a hundred thousand
vulnerable refugees and
in host community children um in in both
host communities and refugee camps
and they have about 150 centers across
jordan
um it's a comprehensive approach so
part of a part of the makani programming
is around
education but it also is a well-rounded
approach
providing child protection services
childhood development they want to
provide
life skills training and innovation labs
for adolescents and
youth as well as integrating
uh health and nutrition programming
through through wash services and so as
a whole the makani programs aim to
promote and contribute to
um children's youth and and parents full
development and well-being
um sort of across the board of you know
physical cognitive and social
socio-emotional um well-being and so
it's
um an integrative program to improve
um well-being among adolescents
in in bangladesh the main access to
education
for the rohingya adolescents living in
the camps are these temporary learning
centers that were set up
um by unicef and save the children in
partnership with the government of
bangladesh
and the temporary learning centers are
much more focused on
trying to provide learning progression
for children
and adolescents but very much focused on
lower level like young young children
with with the learning um and teaching
focusing on like learning to read in
letters and so
you know our experience with uh older
adolescents through qualitative
interviews is that they find the program
sort of boring and
like too low level um and
they there was some
discussion about expanding these
temporary learning centers to provide
the burmese curriculum um
for the rohingya adolescence in in
bangladesh and that was supposed to be
expanded
in 2020 however that was put on hold
due to the onset of of kovid and
in fact these temporary learning centers
have been completely closed since last
year
um in april and so access to education
is again um essentially non-existent for
for rohingya adolescents
so around both of these programs we
have done some work um sort of
evaluating
uh the impact of these learning
opportunities
um and programming on adolescent
outcomes
and at this point given that we just
have you know baseline
data we're comparing outcomes according
to makani participation
or the temporary learning center
participation
um and then we control for factors that
are
relevant to selection into participation
so we're controlling for
age sex and and nationality which um
have been found in other literature to
be important drivers for participation
and then in addition we control for
household resources through
asset indices whether the household head
is literate um
whether it's a female-headed household
and the location and so in jordan that's
um in a camp its or host community and
in bangladesh that's comparing
um it's we're focused part in the camps
solely for the temporary learning
centers and so that's comparing sort of
technology to
um ukiya which are the two upazillas
where the camps are are located
and then um where we estimate when we're
doing this analysis we also separate out
our adolescents into the two age cohorts
um 10 to 14 year olds and 15 to 17 year
olds because
both programs um focus
on sort of adolescents under the age of
15 and most makani participants are
under the age of 10.
um and then as i mentioned already the
tlc participation is younger adolescence
so first i just want to talk a little
bit on access to education and i have a
couple of figures here
which is estimated using the um
the jordan data looking at the impact of
makani
and with the two figures um the first is
for the young cohort 10 to 14 year old
looking through a range of education
outcomes including enrollment
in formal and non-formal schooling as
well as
test scores um focusing a little bit on
math scores and then the second figure
is for the older cohort 15 to 18 year
olds
and one of the things i just want to
highlight what you can see is that
you know adolescents who are enrolled in
makani
or have ever been enrolled in makani are
more likely to be currently enrolled
in in schooling and non-formal schooling
and that they tend to have better test
scores
but that these seem to be especially
manifesting for the older adolescents
the
15 to 18 year olds even though they may
not currently be enrolled in makani sort
of pointing toward
um supportive role that makani may have
played
when they were younger to carry them
forward for better outcomes in in later
later adolescents and then um we don't
have as wide of a range of
of outcomes um for
the rohingya camps but the temporary
learning centers
also increased the likelihood of
enrollment in non-formal education by
about 64 percentage points
um just to note that the temporary
learning centers
account for about um
50 of the enrollment in education
um sorry about 50 of adolescents are
enrolled in the temporary learning
centers
for the non-formal education so a lot of
this is is driven by the enrollment in
the non-formal education centers
themselves
um so now you know turning
to violence and here i'm going to talk a
bit about
more like daily violence that
adolescents are facing
um in their lives uh sorry jennifer just
one jordan a question
one question from the chat before you go
on is just the questions do the
temporary learning centers include child
spaces as as well how how exactly are
they
set up yeah
um so they do have um
child-friendly spaces i will um
have to check specifically on on how
those are structured and perhaps when
um sarah takes back over in the second
half and i can come back to respond to
that toward the end
thanks um
so in jordan sort of day-to-day
um experience of violence
um has tens in terms of reporting from
adolescence
focuses around um sexual harassment by
adolescent girls is commonly
reported um in the qualitative work
there's discussion of boys and young men
tend to stand around outside girls
schools as they leave and follow them
home
and so this is a common occurrence
nearly half of the adolescents are
reporting violence at home and this
is potentially you know violent
discipline um from parents but this is
much more heavily
um a higher burden is carried by
boys with 42 of boys mothers admitting
to using violent discipline compared to
31
of um of girls mothers
and we have a quote here from a syrian
mother
talking about how she does not beat her
daughter because this will affect her
but when i beat my son he will be better
at sort of this viewpoint of variance
and discipline between
male and female children and then um
bullying is
is common so 46 of 38 percent of girls
report
experiencing um peer violence
which could include um like
physical violence as well as as name
calling
the picture is really very similar in
uh in bangladesh where um
you know both camp and host communities
um
adolescent girls are reporting um sexual
harassment and gender-based violence
um you know 15 of of married girls
report having experienced
some form of gender-based violence
um and then again pure violence and
bullying is common with 45 percent of
adolescents experiencing pair violence
and this is across both camp and host
communities so i would note that um
peer violence is more commonly reported
in in host communities in this context
worth
54 of adolescents reporting some
form of peer violence in host
communities versus 30
in camps
and one of the big um
challenges in terms of violence comes uh
with
early marriage um and married
adolescents which we've already talked a
little bit about
earlier in the presentation um but just
to reiterate
in in jordan 18 of the
um 15 to 17 year olds in the sample
almost entirely syrian were already
married
and in bangladesh the share is a little
lower but we found in our own sample
among 15 to 17 year old girls about 12
of the females were already married and
among
um married adolescents in both jordan
and
bangladesh among the rohingya refugee
camps uh
the qualitative work very strongly
presented
um evidence of gender-based violence and
so i've
chosen a selection of quotes here
from from both communities these two
these two quotes here you know girls are
abused by their husbands are both
in jordan context you know he used to
pour water in my ears because these
things don't leave any marks on the
outside
in the rohingya camps ipv is happening
within marriages but it's very well
known
even to unknown girls and so this is a
quote from a 16 year old unmarried
girl who says she has heard a lot about
this from many persons when wives don't
listen to their husbands they're beaten
and you know just to point out that the
solutions to these
um are not
um they're not well supported and so in
the rohingya camps there's a lot of
reporting that there's no one
reliable to report to or they aren't
listened to when they do report
and in in jordan you know one of the
main outcomes is divorce in in these
settings
um so then turning toward
uh mental health um and then we'll kind
of do a deeper dive
in our survey and what we focus on we're
measuring mental health primarily using
the general health questionnaire 12
which asks about
how you've been feeling in the you know
last two weeks compared to normal
and then we use the child and youth
resilience measure
to measure uh resilience
and in jordan what we find is that most
adolescents are not psychologically
distressed and that they are emotionally
resilient so
i'm using the general health
questionnaire 12 um
to measure psychological distress around
a third of of adolescents
had scores that demonstrated emotional
distress
but this varied across populations and
so
in the jordan context older girls are 11
more likely to be distressed
than older boys
and in bangladesh you know rates of
emotional distress measured by the ghq12
are much are lower around half of what's
reported
in um in jordan but there are
significant differences between older
and younger adolescents with you know 20
percent of
older adolescents reporting
psychological distress compared to 10
of younger adolescents and actually the
most affected
group in bangladesh is around the older
males
and particularly in the rohingya camps
and
in the qualitative work one of the major
concerns that came
out is um financial reasons and um
boys you know shouldering a majority of
the concern about the you know work that
they need to do to contribute to
household incomes
um so again kind of thinking back to
the programming and and what exists and
um how we might be able to think about
supporting
the psychosocial well-being of
adolescents
we have looked at among younger
adolescents the role
of the makani programming and the
temporary learning centers
on you know resilience and
psychosocial mental health is measured
by the ghq12 and what we find in both
contexts
and this is particularly driven by young
boys and so these are the results
that i'm showing here is that being
currently enrolled
in makani or currently attending an ngo
program
reduces the ghq 12
score by about 0.3
points and in bangladesh this translates
to about an 11 percentage point
reduction
in the likelihood of experiencing
psychological distress
um which is you know given that among
young adolescents as a whole
around you know ten percent of them were
experiencing psychological distress this
is quite a large
large effect and that you know
adolescents that are engaging in this
programming
are having better outcomes i'm
suggesting that supportive environments
are
are crucial in these cases
um and then finally i do just want to
mention
you know one uh again coming back to
early marriage and the negative impacts
that this has on adolescence as
you know alongside gender-based violence
one of the things that we found in some
recent work
um i've been doing on early marriage in
the rohingya population is that when you
look at
phq9 scores which is another um you know
clinical diagnostic tool
for a moderate to severe depression um
37
of our married adolescent girls exhibit
signs of moderate to severe depression
um compared to 11 of the older unmarried
girls in the rohingya camps and so
um you know early marriage although
maybe
potentially protective is is causing a
fair amount of distress
sorry jennifer one question before you
um move on
um so is disorder divorce socially
acceptable or are there some
repercussions for girls who get
divorced do they go back to live with
their parents is probably they're sort
of not economically
active i can speak to jordan in that um
it's yes there you know
is stigma um associated with being
divorced and yes
they do typically go back to live in
their homes
but it has become so common
so you know kind of and and
these many of these girls do then go
into marry again fairly quickly so yes
stigma but it's at least in jordan has
become
um very common and i don't know jennifer
if you can speak to bangladesh
yeah in the rohingya context um
the divorce did not come up um
strongly in the in the research on early
marriage and and my understanding from
the context is it's not
um it's not socially acceptable and it's
it's
um and so it's not really an option
um in that context
that we have about 25 minutes left total
yeah so i'm gonna i think some of this
motivation slides i'll be going through
a little bit quickly since we've already
kind of provided that motivation
so what i want to talk about here and i
think i'll focus a little bit on mental
health measurement
um is some work that we're doing using
children's drawings
uh to to measure as is potential
measures of mental health in these
contexts so i have a few slides here
sort of motivating
mental health and adolescence which we
already discussed earlier and
um you know degrees of mental health
uh illness among among
refugees so i'll go go through this
quickly
but what i do want to stop and talk
about is that you know a big challenge
in terms of measuring mental health in
these contexts is um you know how to
assess psychological distress for very
young adolescents particularly when
we're talking about 10 and 12 year olds
although you know the gh2 12 has been
validated in multiple populations
administering these complex survey
instruments in you know potentially
um fragile contexts can be can be
difficult and especially in cases where
adolescents have limited education and
are struggling to understand concepts
and so one promising methodology is
children's self-portraits um
and and free drawings and these have
been used in clinical settings as a
gauge of mental health in other contexts
and there has been some recent research
using children's drawings for measuring
psychological impacts
in um in field studies and so we're
building on this
to look at the feasibility in in our
context
as well
um so you know the empirical literature
has established
a link between some characteristics of
children's self-portraits and free
drawings
and elements of psychological health and
i'll show some examples of what that
might look like in a couple slides
um and the nice thing about drawings is
that if we can associate
you know features of drawings to mental
health we might be able to learn
um things about mental health that would
be difficult to obtain from direct
questioning either because
adolescents don't want to respond
directly or don't understand
the the concepts themselves and so what
we're doing with these drawings is um
we basically give the adolescents a
sheet of paper and a set of colored
pencils and a
and a flat place to draw and we give
them simple instructions
so we do both free drawings in the gauge
context and then we have um
from another data set uh self portraits
but essentially the instructions are i'd
like you to draw a picture on this piece
of paper using these pencils
and feel free to draw whatever you're
thinking about it can be a picture of
anything
and they have 15 minutes and if it's a
self-portrait then we just specify
that um
so we have these drawings from two data
sets among
syrian refugee families and so one was
collected in 2016
um by um colleagues at university of san
francisco bruce wydeck
rafael panlulio and stephanie smith
collaborating with us on this work
and then they have data on children five
ages five to twelve and then we have the
gauge jordan data that we've been
talking about today focusing
particularly on the syrian adolescents
aged
10 to 12 and um for the usf data set we
have
portraits and for the gauge
jordan data set we have free drawings
and then we're able to use these surveys
that collect
information on household characteristics
and governance of origin
in syria and pair it with exposure to
trauma
which we measure using the syrian
revolution martyr database which
contains information on
sort of number of martyr deaths in
governance
by you know timing um in
in syria and so we're able to link when
adolescents
travel to jordan from syria to sort of
the timing
of martyr deaths um in syria to
measure the exposure the extent of
exposure they've had to this violence
and then in the future we do have
drawings in the gauge bangladesh data as
well
although it's currently still in in
bangladesh
so that we could you know bring that
into this work as well
so just um as an example of how features
of drawings might be used to measure um
mental health so tibbetts 20 um
tidbits and some previous work in 2013
has
identified some features of drawings
that can be linked to ptsd
and so some of those might be like in
this drawing of the flag you know lack
of concern with integrating background
into drawing
perhaps um you know focus on symbols or
memories of
trauma um so that could be um
here is a picture um it's like a man
aiming a gun at another person and so
these are both features that have been
associated with ptsd
and then there's other literature such
as work um by watterson
um as old as far back as 1971 linking
features of drawings to
anxiety and depression and so one might
be drawn in dark colors so this is the
black and white
picture of a hat or with a single color
of a house
excuse me um or even you know positive
features of drawings
indicating low anxiety or happiness so
having you know bright colors
etc and so then this is how we've had we
have these drawings and we're when we
code them according to these features
and then are able to classify them into
indicators of depression anxiety or ptsd
that we then use as measures of mental
health
and then we estimate the relationship of
these measures of mental health
that we build from the indices using a
simple regression
outcome is our index of anxiety
depression or ptsd and then
x is our um is a vector of refugee
experiences that includes exposure to
violence or simulation and then we
control
for various household characteristics
and what we find is that um
exposure to violence is measured by the
syrian modern martyr database
is um positively correlated or
indicating higher levels of ptsd
as measured by these drawing indexes um
both
in the usf data among the five to
12 year olds in 2016 and in the gauge
jordan data um um
measured more recently in 2018 2018-2019
and then in this data we're also able to
measure um
integration of the syrian refugees into
jordan communities so those living in
host communities and we can see that
adolescents that have been reintegrated
into jordan society that
um this is these supportive environments
um
are associated with reductions in um
experience of of ptsd and the usf data
and then also reductions in experience
of depression
and anxiety across across both data sets
and so what we see is that
these measures of anxiety depression and
ptsd as indices
of mental health sorry indices of
drawing features are associated with
these past exposures to violence
so then what we want to do is identify
in particular features of these drawings
that are associated
most associated with exposure to
violence and then whether these same
features of drawings can be associated
with more traditional measures of mental
health such as the ghq12
and we do that using um lasso
which um is a tool to identify
to identify basically the most important
correlates with
an outcome of interest
and so we use lasso to estimate the
following specification
where we have our outcome in this case
is now exposure to violence and we're
trying to predict the violence with
drawing features which we have here um
in this d
feature and we penalize these drawing
features in order to identify the most
important drawing features
in this case and then we have our
control variables that we don't penalize
that are household characteristics
and we estimate this lasso separately on
each of the two data sets the usf data
set and the gauge data set and what we
find is in both cases
the drawing of aggressive action figures
is
retained as being highly predictive of
exposure to violence and so this is the
most important feature
but i but you can also see other
features that were retained through the
through the lasso estimation um in each
data set as well including you know
shading a face of body
um monster pictures as also being
positively correlated
with um with violence and so what we're
seeing is that
there are strong correlations of these
drawing features as being able to
predict
um higher exposures of violence measured
through the syrian database
um and then just very quickly
we then took those features that were
identified as predictive of violence and
can also show that they
are correlated also with signs of
psychological distress which we mainly
point out here to say that these
features are identifying something that
is correlated with with mental health
um as well so that we aren't just
talking about violence and drawing but
but also can really link this back to
mental health
so i will wrap up there and um
and hand back to to sarah
great um thanks jennifer
um you know i think there's a number of
questions in the chat and i'll make sure
we
i leave you know five minutes to to get
back to these i mean i think
mental health measurement in general
mental health measurement among
adolescents
um you know is something where continued
research is
is needed one thing that um
you know for example it seems like some
of the rates of
of symptoms of psychological distress
are lower among these populations than
typical adolescents in low middle income
countries and that may be partially
because
you know anxiety is such a is almost
normalized for them
and so i think we need to do a bit more
to to figure that out and then i think
you know
one there was a query around access to
to services and i think you know yes
there's stigma around mental health and
then even if you identify it there's
limited access to services
i know there are a lot of innovative
low-cost um methodologies
being explored but i really think this
is is you know a place where
um a lot more research is is needed okay
so i have about 10
minutes um so i'm not going to really do
this this part
justice but given that i think covet 19
is is on the top of our
our minds and particularly given the
massive
increases in cases in in bangladesh as
well as in in jordan
um i think it's totally uh salient for
these
settings i'm going to skip um most of
these slides but just highlight kind of
a few things that have come out of our
of our research uh next slide
so very quickly just you know for those
of you that perhaps don't don't
work in these contexts and haven't been
following what's happening with kovid
that'd be nice to just provide a graphic
of kind of the trajectory of covet 19
cases over time and key
policy moments of most relevance for
this conversation
is that when we conducted the the first
round of covid
data collection back in in may um jordan
had one of the most strict the strictest
lockdowns
globally and cases were very very low
um when we are resumed our second round
of field work in late 2020 early 2021
um they had largely uh relaxed those
restrictions
cases were um increasing pretty
dramatically and schools tried to reopen
briefly but then had to shut down um and
in fact you know
last march was actually the highest case
caseload in jordan
thus far and so they're i think things
are starting to to turn
um but sort of you know second round of
data collection was taking place when
when there was a fairly high rise
next slide
so in bangladesh it's uh it's sort of a
similar story
um when we conducted data collection in
um
april may 2020 um the government had
actually imposed a very strict lockdown
on cox's bazar specifically to prevent
the spread of the virus in the camps
um this included um closing all the the
learning centers and sort of
other non-essential ngo programs
data collection as i mentioned is still
ongoing um right now um but similarly
cases are rising dramatically bangladesh
announced another lockdown on
april 5th with sort of a more severe
lockdown set to start to
tomorrow uh complementing this there
were actually
horrible fires in the camps sort of
further
you know preventing challenges on their
lives and and up to today as far as i
know not a single rohingya has received
a vaccination
next slide next slide
next like
right so you know adolescents obviously
are not really being affected by the the
direct
health impacts um but school closures
and
and the economic disruption um has been
huge
we collaborated to develop a module just
asking for both the adult and the
adolescent their perspective on on how
covet has impacted their community
across a variety of different dimensions
and as you can see almost everyone
notes that people have lost jobs and
schools have clothes and also lots of
people
noting increases in violence people
using
shisha and other types of substances
people unable to get medical care and
then issues around self-harm
and suicide and this has also come out
in the qualitative work so this just
highlights
you know how dramatic this this shock
has been as perceived by these
households next slide
similarly in bangladesh so here these
are from the adults perspective
comparing coast and camp and once again
you know most households have
effect had some sort of um
employment or income loss schools have
closed and people are perceiving
you know increased anxiety increased
violence um
food insecurity etc so the
you know the while the direct health
effects um have not been
at least to date perhaps as large as
they have been in places like the u.s
you know the lockdowns in these contexts
have sort of massively destructed these
people's
lives next slide
all right so i'm going to just focus on
a few key
results um this is the first one which
is around food insecurity so we asked
the adolescents
how many meals they had with animal
protein yesterday
this also includes some data from our
other sites
and i guess perhaps not surprisingly
given the magnitude of the economic
shock
you can see that when you compare
baseline so this is pre-covered
to covet round one which is the early
pandemic and to jordan in covet round
two
you can see that the number of meals
with animal protein dropped
um substantially and in jordan we we
still haven't seen any
um sign of recovery so the
economic effects and then its
translation into food insecurity which
as
sort of mushvik and i we're talking at
the in the beginning i think the
nutrition is particularly important for
for adolescent growth and so this is
something to be
to be concerned about next slide
in jordan we can also further look at
differences in experiences between hosts
informal tented settlements and camps um
here we're looking at whether
adolescents experience hunger in the
last four weeks
so again you see these sort of increases
at covet r1
and in both host and its really no sign
of
recovery but in camps you can see that
it does look like there has been some
improvement and this points to the
extensive access to social protection
that adolescents have in camps that is
not
um not is not there in hosts in igs
communities
next slide
so i'm not going to do this justice but
i really just want to quickly note that
jordan has actually done a
fantastic job relative to other
countries in terms of
um quickly pivoting to online learning
and given the
access to technology
etc you can see that many um most kids
are able to engage in some
learning through this ministry of
education
program even so you can see through
these qualitative quotes that you know
it's unclear how much learning is
actually happening and i think there's a
lot of concern
about what happens when schools um
reopen after this sort of lost year of
education but you know
again relative to other contexts jordan
has you know i think is is a exemplar in
terms of
ability to pivot to to online learning
and i think benefits from from
its wide access to to internet uh next
slide
in bangladesh you know it's a bit of the
opposite
um so i'll just focus on the purple
um shape only six percent of
bangladeshis report
using any kind of media to continue
learning and there's literally only one
rohingya adolescent in our sample who's
had any sort of access to to learning
through media during
during the the pandemic so this
you know i think highlights um the fact
that the pandemic really is going to
exacerbate these pre-existing
inequalities both across and within
countries and we're going to need to
think of a programming that's going to
particularly focus on that
next slide
okay so i'm going to i guess quickly go
through a couple final
themes so you know we think a lot about
about school
closures and how that has isolated
adolescents
you know much [ __ ] was saying he had to
come back from the beach because his his
son wanted to interact with friends
again and and
you know social connectedness is
actually extremely important for for
adolescents and isolation is
associated with mental health anxiety
and other outcomes so
he did good by his by his son um so this
highlights basically how isolated many
of these adolescents
are prior to the pandemic pretty much
everyone was interacting with a friend
or non-household member
at least once in the last seven days but
as you can see
um in in jordan only about 30
of of both boys and girls were
interacting with friends at all
some signs of recovery right so we see
by code round two um those numbers have
increased
but importantly they've increased a lot
more for boys than girls and so girls
are still are
increasingly disadvantaged in terms of
these social connections
and then looking at the cox bizarre
panel survey for round one
this really just highlights the gender
discrepancies in in social connectedness
and how
um how much girls have been sort of
socially isolated from their
their networks and i think you know
alongside school return
we need to think about how we re you
know reestablish these these social
um these social connections next slide
uh next slide
next slide
um so i very quickly on this so um
you know it sounds like from the
comments that a lot of you are
interested in in sort of measurement
issues as well
um so you know and so one challenge we
face in pivoting to a virtual survey is
we have a lot of sensitive questions
and very rigorous policies around
connecting
adolescents to services if they you know
self-report
um you know whether it's exposure to
violence or something else
and so we didn't feel that we could um
adequately protect their privacy
or connect them to services in the
context of the copen 19 pandemic
so instead of acting directly about um
exposure to violence we developed a
series of vignettes that basically asked
about whether
a specific type of violence was a
challenge for adolescents like them and
whether they thought it had increased
since covid
and so this kind of gives you a sense of
the types of questions we were asking
and
you know the the proportion of the
population that was
saying that this was a challenge that
had increased since covet as a way to
get a sense of how the
the pandemic is affecting violence as
well as things like access to
um feminine hygiene products
um next slide
and just the same sort of set of
vendetts for for bangladesh and i think
in general
um you know highlighting violence is
pervasive
and that the there has been some
increases since since copenhagen
next slide
so i'll just end with this finding um
before
um opening it up for any final questions
so you know there's a lot of concern
around whether covet 19 is going to
exacerbate
um child marriage right so i think you
know we've highlighted
the particular vulnerabilities of girls
who are already married and our coven 19
findings
indicate that they have als they have
been disproportionately affected along
many dimensions
but obviously there's also concerned
about currently non-married girls and
whether this is going to sort of
accelerate their transition to
to marriage well i think it's too early
in our quantitative data to be able to
look at changes in in marriage rates an
interesting dichotomy
appeared when we asked them whether they
thought their pressure to marry had
decreased or whether they worried about
marrying
earlier we actually see that quite a few
adolescents actually believe that the
pressure to marry has has decreased
um in both bangladesh and and jordan
this could be for multiple reasons one
is
marriage brings a financial burden and
many of these households simply can't
afford that
right now second marriage comes with a
ceremony and and lots of people
gathering and kova doesn't allow that to
to happen
and then third you know sort of getting
back to some of the conversation
um jennifer and music was having is i
think given that girls are
stuck at home there's less concern about
um their sort of sexual purity and their
exposure to
um kind of violence outside of the
household and so
perhaps also a little bit less rushed to
get them
married and have kids etc on the other
hand you know we do
have a other subset of the population
who are concerned about marrying earlier
and so it'll be you know one of the
beauties about this data being embedded
in longitudinal work is we'll be able to
see over time
um what actually happened with with
marriage
rates as a result of covid and and
whether you know
this we are actually seeing this this
dichotomy and and this actually
comes out in a lot of our cova data is
you know certain households saying
they're getting a lot more support
others saying they're getting a lot less
and so
exploring those dichotomies in in
attitudes um i think will be important
in looking at sort of postcovid
recovery next slide
and if you can just go to the
conclusions jennifer
right so i basically we you know
highlighted some of the vulnerabilities
as adolescents looked at risk of
and protective factors and explored the
impact of of covid
um you know i think we have a lot more
to say but hopefully this has given you
a broad sense of
what our research is is about next slide
as i mentioned you know this is
longitudinal work that will continue
through 2024
um so we have one to two more rounds in
each each context to both look at
post-code recovery
improve measures and understand the
transitions to
adulthood we're very deeply engaged with
policy makers
globally to ensure that research
findings inform policy and programming
all data will be publicly archived um so
you know this as we go this data will be
available for others and we do really
welcome
broad multi-disciplinary um
collaboration and hope that some of you
will reach out to us with
um you know with research ideas or
desire to
to collaborate next slide
uh next slide
a ton of gauge publications on the
the website i encourage you to go look
at it if any of this has interest you
and then final slide
and just here's our contact information
and and the website and you know really
appreciate the
the discussion today um because i know i
haven't been able to get to all the
questions in the chat box but i really
realize we're we're out of time but
happy to follow up you know for you to
follow up
um by email and happy to answer those
those questions so really appreciate you
giving us the opportunity to present
these these findings um
and look forward to further discussions
i uh thank you both uh sarah and
jennifer
uh for the really nice presentation and
give an overview and i'll just add to
that that
um they've both been wonderful people to
collaborate with so this uh
invitation to collaborate that they've
sent out broadly
i'm just endorsing the fact that they're
wonderful to work